all right let's talk about the
outpouring of tributes actor Lance
Reddick he died Friday at the age of 60
of natural causes Redick was best known
for his roles as Baltimore cop Cedric
Daniels on the acclaimed drama the wire
wow yes and Sharon in the John Wick
franchise red ex-wife Stephanie wrote on
his Instagram quote Lance was taken from
us far too soon thank you for your
overwhelming love support and beautiful
story shared on these platforms over the
last day I see your messages and can't
begin to express how grateful I am to
have them active Viola Davis who worked
with Reddick wrote on social media quote
this talented kind intelligent King is
gone and thousands of players of the
video game Destiny saluted Reddick who
voiced Commander Zavala in the popular
game so he was so Monumental on so many
different platforms television and film
and even in video I was so sorry to hear
it especially at the age of 60 to hear
his natural causes so he just leaves us
far too soon and I believe uh the
upcoming John Wick film is going to be
dedicated in his honor it's coming up